greets everyone - I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel white today we are talking
about outraged culture ironically I
think some people are gonna get angry
from watching this video it's ironic
because that's what this video is about
people getting angry all the time
but I think I'm talking about a side of
this that I mean I've never seen covet
before we already know that there are
people on the internet who are called
sjw so social justice warriors who seem
to get angry about things that seem kind
of insane the idea is that there is a
subset of people who are just offended
by everything and if you say anything
that isn't 100% politically correct
we'll just tell you a pot online I do
believe those people exist I also think
that the presence of them is kind of
exaggerated and today I specifically
wanted to talk about the reverse of that
the anti social justice warriors who get
so outraged by the idea of people being
outraged that they kind of just doing
the same thing everyone's just yelling
at each other and no one wants to admit
that they are you're all angry I don't
know what to tell you
so it's really easy for me to pull
examples of this that have happened to
me where someone has suggested that I
was outraged by something that was
incredibly neutral because they look for
outrage in things or they suggest
outrage that isn't actually there or
dramatically inflate the presence of it
a really good example of this is there's
a video on my channel that is top five
hottest men in games when I posted that
video loads of people said stuff like if
a man did this it would be considered
sexist feminists would be angry about it
basically they were saying that if a man
posted a top five hottest women in games
video that sjw's would be outraged so I
want at the comments on the thousands of
top five hottest women in games videos
and found very little of this point
being I think the presence of outrage is
exaggerated and I mean that works on a
professional scale as well I've had this
really great article about this woman
who toured with Maya innopolis for a
while and she basically reported that
cheering's - is they would kind of fake
outrage
so that Mylo supporters would be like I
can't believe people are offended by
this and then would show up they would
leak things that weren't true saying
that people were trying to get my load
banned from attending a certain College
sure it has happened in some instances
but she's a first-hand source for saying
that they also lied about it in order to
make other people outraged this is legit
we used as a business strategy and it
obviously works very well because I can
say something that's super neutral and
people will complain about everyone's PC
it's ruining everything
I can't have freedom of speech anymore I
said that I didn't want to play outlaws
too because I read the classification
listing for the reason why it was banned
in Australia and people legitimately
complained about PC culture ruining
everything this is a ratings board in
Australia that has only recently gotten
the re team rating it's it's getting
less PC they're allowing less safe
things this is not a result of the
opposite we people used to get arrested
for swearing on the street like really
political correctness is not killing you
I recently tweeted something disagreeing
with feminist frequency and I had a
bunch of replies from people who said be
careful feminists getting angry at you
or sjw's gonna unfollow you now none of
that happened they would do it just five
tweets from people saying that that
would happen but none of it happened
I just think both sides of this
exaggerate everything
please don't get outraged by this is it
a perception is it marketing do you even
care about the stuff that you think you
care about or do you just like the way
that someone else sold it to you
all rightie that is it for me today you
guys I will see you guys next time okay